how are you feeling going into uh this
uh this fed meeting and uh giving all
the recent price action with bitcoin
feeling good yeah i mean 50 from the
highs a little less than that i guess um
but when we were at 33 000 uh a little
more than 50 i mean for me like i i love
it the volatility uh like i kind of said
at the end of the thread is
my opportunity people that are buying
bitcoin it's your opportunity uh if
bitcoin wasn't volatile then the returns
wouldn't be so good um and so yeah i
mean at 20 years old i'm i'm loving it
uh continuing to allocate and just uh at
a steady pace so
uh nothing but a thing for me
nothing but a j thing baby all right
well let's talk about bitcoin uh
correlation to nasdaq we've got the
chart here uh these these things are
married to each other right now they
just seem to be moving up and down
wherever one goes the other one goes how
do you think about uh these assets the
correlation and then who's leading who
yeah so put this uh put this thread out
on uh on sunday uh so charts a little
bit outdated but yeah i mean they've
been trading tick for tick with each
other especially during the us uh cash
session so
um
you know it's it's for now right
everything is about the fed and really
markets are front running
the fed right they're they're giving the
fed a gut check and saying oh you're
going to raise rates all right well the
vix will blow out to 38 and and markets
are going to tank
and you actually saw the funny thing was
you saw like the prediction market for
the fed's fund rate as everything was
tanking
it started to to cut back on some of
those rate hikes that priced in uh so
that that expected fed's fund rate at
the end of the year as markets were
tanking it actually was tanking with it
so it was almost like the fed put was
being priced in as markets were tanking
and so i think the correlation stays
steady for for the time being right
everything is just kind of a reflection
of this everything bubble liquidity and
bitcoin is like the most pure form of
that it's just a check on central bank
irresponsibility and so if central banks
get marginally more responsible uh with
their monetary policy the fed mainly uh
then bitcoin is is gonna get hit as a
result and that's fine because you know
there's there's multiple types of
allocators of this asset class you know
there's the bitcoiners right that just
stack huddle uh got that uh huddle
mindset and then embrace the volatility
and then there's you know the macro fund
managers that are running correlations
and and flipping nasdaq and bitcoin and
arc and all of these things is kind of a
risk-on type of asset and so um you know
there's multiple different allocators
but i think 2020 and 2021 we saw a lot
more of these kind of macro correlation
uh type funds come in
and that's who's been the marginal
seller as of late
and so when you start to think about uh
kind of the fed the interest rate
decision uh there's a couple of other
things that we can look at right so the
first one let's say uh on the re on the
fed rate hikes uh the euro dollar
futures uh continues to price in four
rate hikes uh when we look at this
how much like weight i guess do you put
on to things like euro dollar futures
yeah so i mean essentially i just like
to look at it as
a gauge for what the market expects and
so since about november you've seen
you've seen that really spike up uh when
the fed first came out and said yeah
okay guys you were right inflation's not
transitory uh this is our mandate to
keep it contained we might have to do
something uh that's when you kind of saw
bitcoin first really reacted to it uh
from the highs and started to started to
sell off um and then the nasdaq followed
and so you know i don't put too much
weight into your dollar futures uh like
if the fed raised rates to one percent
uh and and the financial system is so
fragile that i can't handle it well
that's just uh i think that's just
saying uh how much we need bitcoin right
because ultimately if there's a
deflationary collapse because the fed
raises rates to one percent and real
yields are still very deep deeply
negative uh you know there's a there's a
bigger problem on our hands but uh on
the shorter time frame like we saw in
say 2020 uh bitcoin is is risk off and
if the dollar is is pumping uh then
bitcoin will we'll see that kind of
liquidity here
got it and so when you start to look at
the actual reasons why bitcoin's price
had exploded uh you rightly call out the
grayscale bitcoin uh trust and the
arbitrage that was happening there
describe to people what that actual
arbitrage was and why so many wall
street funds were going and allocating
capital to grayscale in you know kind of
q3 q4 of uh 2020 and into the beginning
of 2021.
yeah so grayscale was a huge driver
earlier in the bull run i mean obviously
uh there was a lot of of people and
investors that were allocating to
bitcoin the you know the spot asset
itself and taking custody um throughout
the last decade but you know in 2020
after the covet kind of uh meltdown and
then all of that stimulus that followed
but grayscale is an interesting story
and they've been around since uh 2016 i
think a little before that actually um
and they were for the longest time like
the only kind of uh otc product
over-the-counter product that that
traditional accredited investors could
gain access to so if you were an
institution or an accredited investor
you could bring a hundred dollars to
grayscale and they would give you a
hundred dollars worth of gbtc or you
could bring bitcoin to them and they
would give you a hundred dollars worth
of gbtc
um but those gbtc shares they don't
trade like an etf they trade uh on these
otc markets and they have a six month
lock up and so often times because this
was the only game in town for gaining uh
bitcoin exposure in say a retirement
account or on wall street uh these
shares traded at a pretty big premium
right so uh that there would say a
hundred twenty a hundred dollars of
bitcoin in this uh you know share this
share of a trust but on the otc markets
it would trade for say 120. so there was
an interesting arbitrage opportunity
that arose where if you were a fund if
you were an accredited investor you
could bring 100 to grayscale and then
receive 120
of gbtc trust because it was trading at
a 20 premium but there was a six month
lockup so essentially like everyone on
wall street increasingly was like oh my
god this is just
a money printer we could just we can
just get this 20 arbor it often blew out
to even like high 30s um and it was just
basically a way for for wall street
firms especially at the end of 2020 to
just mark up their books with a with a
profit and so uh
this throughout 2020 and uh early 2021
grayscale added about uh 400 000 bitcoin
uh and often days they were i remember
they bought ten thousand twelve thousand
bitcoin at a time on certain days they
they announced it so there was just huge
inflows yeah here's that that uh premium
and discount and at the bottom there uh
is the daily inflows into this product
and so as more and more funds did this
and oftentimes some would hedge so some
would short bitcoin or a bitcoin-like
product say like microstrategy that's
very correlated and then buy these gbtc
shares and they would that premium
whatever that gbtc premium was to net
asset value that was their that was
their uh essentially their their profit
but the trade unwound because of the
six-month lock-up and so many funds
doing it
shares actually on the otc market
started to trade to a discount and so
that's when things got got kind of hairy
for a lot of these funds was the arms
that they thought they had that's quote
unquote risk-free arb uh wasn't
risk-free and so a lot of a lot of those
funds implementing that trade uh kind of
unwound on them and so uh there was
there's you know 650 000 bitcoin now or
a little bit less than that um that are
trading uh basically as a derivative in
in terms of gbtc shares that are trading
to a discount uh to net asset value on
secondary markets and so uh throughout
the last couple months you've seen uh as
the nasdaq has sold off as bitcoin has
sold off as kind of there's been a risk
off sentiment in markets gbtc discount
has reached record lows it actually hit
a 30 discount in that asset value so
what that's saying is that basically all
these macro funds that allocated to this
uh in 2020 and 2021 are just you know
basically relentlessly market dumped uh
these products under the secondary
market and so that actually had an
effect on the bitcoin market because if
you're a fund and you want to allocate
to bitcoin do you buy bitcoin or do you
buy uh gbtc at a 30 discount to net
asset value so on the margin it's
actually siphoned away uh for the time
being siphoned away from spot demand um
so an interesting kind of opportunity as
it went both ways it almost like
artificially boosted the price of
bitcoin early in the bull market and now
it's stifling a little bit of demand but
interesting arbitrage opportunities on
both sides so when you look at the gbtc
uh for those to to make sure they really
hammer this home is you had all these
wall street folks who were going and
they were arbiting it they were
investing in the private market they
were then flipping it for an additional
profit in the public market it was like
the greatest secret bitcoin trade on
wall street history right and then all
of a sudden when the market started to
cool off people started to get worried
you got a premium that switched to a
discount then they all started to sell
because now they're going risk off and
so there's still a bunch of wall street
folks or kind of large institutional
investors they want exposure to bitcoin
they don't need to go buy spot bitcoin
because they can just simply go buy gbtc
and if they've got the appetite to hold
it until you get a closing uh back to
nav it actually is not only giving you
bitcoin exposure it's giving you bitcoin
exposure plus the discount that you're
getting which now has reached you know
levels of 30 35 on some days uh so it's
pretty attractive in terms of
if you're a long-term holder on wall
street just go buy this public market
fund and it takes away that spot demand
which obviously has an impact on the
price because there's not people buying
spot bitcoin they're simply buying this
kind of synthetic or indirect exposure
is that a fair way to kind of summarize
it
yep you nailed it i mean you know
depending on when that spot etf is
approved and i think grayscale uh the
consensus is that they're one of the
leaders for when when to get approved i
mean 650 000 bitcoin that's that's quite
a substantial amount and so they'd
definitely be one of the most liquid
products in the world i think in terms
of etfs if they were an etf they'd be uh
in terms of assets under management top
50 in the world um and so you know
they're definitely a market leader in
the spot etf race it's up to gensler for
when it comes but you know if if gbtc is
trading to a 30 discount in that asset
value and say you know base case it
takes three years for a spot etf to be
approved which i think uh it'll be a lot
sooner than that then you're basically i
guess if you factor in the two percent
annual fee but more or less like a
you're performing outperforming bitcoin
by 10 annually if it takes three years
and these are you know back of the
napkin type type math here but uh it's
basically just a way almost a guaranteed
way if a spot etf conversion happens to
outperform bitcoin and so obviously
there's not the self-custody kind of
characteristics uh like bitcoin the
native asset gives you uh but in terms
of you know secondary exposure
retirement accounts or you know for fund
managers it's definitely a pretty good
opportunity